I started doing what calacas Kowalik
koala I knew Percy kalila goes on you
should not smoke so on and on so I quit
smoking five months ago okay so have no
more snow more smoking okay this is a
new thing it's become vegetarians oh
[ __ ] you jumped on yeah seven days no
bro did I force you into it no but you
know what I'm condescending the way you
say it
no you won't she's like you're not gonna
be able to do it so I'm not even gonna
only way to get you to do anything is to
say you do a psychotic reverse
psychology 101 yeah but I fall for it
every [ __ ] time
alright if you want me to do anything
that's how you doing week I was like
please don't do it cuz it's not like
you're gonna last more than a day please
just don't join in and he's 7 days into
it that's a veggie burger he's you know
that's impressive
I'm eating a veggie burger right now and
look it's only for the month of January
it's just the trial and it's not it's
not that I don't believe in eating meat
I just hate like the agribusiness and
how everything is just like
mass-produced and all that yourself yeah
but anyway but here's the thing that it
it so with the black mirror and the
veget to that just [ __ ] that
vegetarianism and I have to say the only
positive is I've never had such fruitful
shits what is a fruitful [ __ ] it's it's
it just keeps on giving
thank you sorry I've never had my poop
bind yeah he's always that scattered poo
mine's like debris yeah that Katrina so
you don't have actually solids it's just
I never but I eat so awfully that if you
look at the inside the toilet is messy
shits before it looks like a leper Oh
God like an aerial view of Aleppo just
just everything s oh you spray odd you
know everything
yeah but with this vegetarian I've never
had I've never had you know Hardy you
know the Lord of the Rings a ring what
does it do it binds
the ring that binds the other people to
binds it together it says it in the
prophecy of the Lord of the Rings that's
what this is doing it's also lost three
pounds and I've gained three pounds
you've gained yeah I think that I I know
that I'm getting enough protein I just
think that by nature of going vegetarian
it's very carb heavy no matter what you
can't get around the fact that you know
it is carb heavier than having a higher
protein meal and that's just the end of
it glucose yeah it's like when I'm
hungry I'm gonna have vegetables and
rice and you know try to get like
protein but yeah I've gained three
pounds I think my body's shutting down
guys it's like what do you guys normally
eat that just that just burgers I know I
still eat eggs I still eat a lot of
veggies eat a lot of vegetables and I
didn't try to combine proteins to make a
whole protein I'm more careful than him
but I'm actually getting the least
benefit he's losing weight I'm gaining
weight it's so sad he's winning he's
winning and this was my idea I like one
of the veggie grill I do
Arclight but there's a couple of them
chained now friend yeah but I like one
of the veggie grill aye aye aye
I've always liked it even when I wasn't
vegetarian because I just like the fact
it tastes like chicken
no but it's like you know fried chicken
Santa Fe sandwich it kind of looks like
tastes like a fried chicken sandwich but
it's not there's also an artificial
robotic androidy kind of vibe to it too
and that's what I like to like it's a
future food I think I mean like like in
a space station Jetsons yeah and they
their nachos are like what aliens
wouldn't make it they heard about nachos
yeah it's not quite there but there's
something weird about it
that's why I like it and then we went to
another restaurant down the street
what's that place down the street or in
Silver Lake over that [ __ ] thing is
Chloe Chloe Chloe really good these new
joints popping up you know maybe we all
can do it you got it what happens if you
get past month will you keep doing it
No
because I know because I want to eat
sushi one day whatever you're a
pescetarian only fish as oh can I do
that now no we have to do the month of
January open up his mind wait arena I
rather be basket area not surprised how
about good you know what you're right
I'm a loser I can't do it I'm weak yeah
I'm a weed guy I'm going to be pest
Ithorian do what you want I'm gonna do
what I want like I want to be it now
reverse psychology you couldn't do it
dude
I do you I did for three months that was
not did you gain weight
yeah a lot of fries that's vegetarian oh
okay I don't dude I'm eating less but
getting fat maybe it's my thyroid
what's the agriculture business I've
seen talks about it you know yeah it's
they raise cows in humanely yeah but
also in so much abundance and we were
just so wasteful with with everything
like how we consume how we produce all
of that is just wasteful and it's not
I'm my I'm not opposed to eating meat if
it's like responsibly sourced and all of
that if I would if I had to Liberty if I
had the skill if I had a skill to hunt
my own [ __ ] to spear fish every day to
grab my own stuff I would absolutely
utilize and eat all animals I just don't
I live in a modern world where I live in
this condo I don't get to do all that
and I feel bad by being this like
wasteful consumer that's the only reason
why really and also I generally think
house are really cute and pigs are smart
and I just I'm getting sensitive I'm
getting really soft watch okhta I
watched oak jar I didn't finished it
Carlos Mencia when I went to Honduras
back in the day I had lived in his
village do you know that if for a month
I lived in because Carlos comes from a
little village in Honduras no running
water no electricity
it's literally prehistoric medieval [ __ ]
but I got used to it
and they've never seen the Asian the
villagers the kids so I was pretty much
like the Elvis of that town you're a
famous I mean I would wake up and I
would have I would be the Pied Piper I'd
walk out of this little building this
Hut and I have 50 kids that follow me
around oh yeah yeah yeah they throw
rocks at my head I don't give a [ __ ]
they thought I was a creature from a
different planet but I am one morning he
goes hey bro that's just the way he
talks in my head yeah
hey bro there's a we're gonna kill a pig
you go check it out bro they flipped
this thing upside down they stuck a
thing in his neck yeah it squealed like
I've never seen anything squeal and I
[ __ ] ate the [ __ ] out of it oh so
hungry but I felt so bad yeah well I've
seen those baby that's that's what I
grew up I you know it's so weird when I
came to the US they would serve they
wouldn't serve a whole lot John which is
so customary in the Philippines to serve
a whole pig with a face and everything
in it and I remember one time we went to
a Filipino party but there were a lot of
different races there and they asked
they asked the the host to put a towel
over the pigs face cuz they couldn't eat
eat the pig with a pig staring at them
which I really never thought was an
issue growing up because that's just how
we do it we roast the whole pig right
don't we put that whole thing in the
table but I think that's a little
hypocritical if you can't look an animal
in the eye while you're eating it then
you feel you don't deserve that food but
is this hypocrite all you eat a [ __ ]
pig then you should be able to eat a dog
a part of that I do agree with I just
don't think that I mean do we need to be
killing 60 different kinds of animals is
what I'm saying I understand but what
I'm saying is is that is it the same
thing essentially yes I think that a
pig's intelligence is very much right
that's what I've been told they're like
dolphins their lands dolphins they're
smart as far south babe yeah they're
incredibly intelligent and I think
they're one of the few that orgasm
wait we quit they orgasm let's
yeah I read that science alert orgasmed
no why would they [ __ ] that not all
animals have sex for pleasure they have
sex out of like an innate drive to
reproduce never seen a fish what if they
what if all animals have orgasms they
just don't make facial expressions but
they feel it no they don't make noises
like I do like oh you know a very vocal
yeah what if I drop this one so good
yeah but that's the way they express it
yeah
are you sure giraffes don't orgasm I'm
not sure I don't know how they even
measure exactly there's no way to do it
because I mean in monkeys at least you
can see that they give they give each
other head they blow each other like
monkeys monkeys jerk-off like riding
they jerk off to me like there was this
one zoo that I went to oftener to show
it off but okay I swear this monkey just
took all day yeah yeah okay look look
look
monkey they're our closest ancestors
right yeah could you
nope what do you mean you mean like wait
what you say no with the smirk on your
face and you're like I know I know could
you could you eat with them yeah of
course okay just hit a little smirk on
your alright good you know but I'm gonna
be real yeah I wouldn't do this I don't
attract it to it yeah what are you gonna
say but can you there's no can you eat
when can you get you have sex with a
monkey of course
bestiality if you want your dick ripped
off they oh they would fight good luck
do you [ __ ] among what if I look warm I
like fancy for a coat what do you mean
no I just like done it up you know I
mean like I wear an armor because I wa
you've seen a gorilla that is
threatening them no I'm gonna just be I
want to like put like yeah I have are
Sam Tripoli okay I grab all your hairs
like what you shave them right I'll just
save all that I'll paste it to my body
Sam tripley's hair it's much like a
monkey yeah let's be real make sure the
monkey is 18 and over
yeah and the monkey was a cruel as a guy
cool
yeah right and then like you know he was
laying on his back him not a girl I mean
oh no you said yeah sorry it's too late
you said him we have to stick with it
all right well then that's weird because
I don't know but there is homosexuality
in the animal kingdom is there yeah
there is of course you see it even but
don't you have a baby could you have a
baby with the monkey no are you [ __ ]
now you sure I don't think that's
possible all right fine I mean is this
even science alert closest ancestors
right there are cousins no man we just
listen man listen friend I saw a Planet
of the Apes okay I did do okay he wants
to make like a human version of a liger
yeah it's like close DNA but then the
baby comes out sterile or I kind of want
to like a mule they said they should
start across I want to meet a centaur
you want to [ __ ] a horse
no no I want to meet one I want to like
a ride a centaur yeah and because you
could talk you know you don't need the
radio I think they probably would be
like doors a half-human right the way so
you're like what I would do a saddle I'm
not gonna put my arms around you know
the human half that's what I'm riding it
really rate basically riding a human
yeah yeah no I'm riding the horse part I
wouldn't hang on to the human part I
would ask can I may put a may I put a
saddle on your back because I'm not
gonna hold your human bugs yeah he's
like no dude my name is Raul I'm and
this is how I do it I don't know your
name has anything to do with it but
alright alright so I'm riding a centaur
right yeah and then you don't even have
to have jams on you can just say what's
up yeah how do you know any of you know
Pegasus you know you could just ask him
questions you know yeah about that I
guess this is like their Jesus oh yeah
yeah well centaurs Jesus yeah
[Music]